MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
come back to 8.701.
In the previous
lectures, we studied
how to read Feynman
diagrams, how
to calculate amplitudes
and phase space.
And we are able to use this
using from Fermi's golden rule
in order to calculate lifetimes
and [INAUDIBLE] cross-sections.
We exercise this with a toy
theory and simple examples.
But we focused on leading
order or tree-level diagrams.
So in this lecture,
I just wanted
to introduce some features of
higher-order diagrams, which
are rather important.
So we started off
with our toy theory
where we have a primitive
vertex where three particles
that are going into action.
The strength of the interaction
or the coupling has--
we just label this as g.
And then we can use
this primitive vertex
in order to build up
scattering processes.
And here we want to consider
the process of two particles
A going to two
particles B. And they
do this by exchanging a particle
C. This is the lowest order
diagram, or sometimes
called the leading order,
or sometimes called
the tree-level diagram.
So how do higher-order
diagrams now look like.
Here's the first example.
And this example is one where
one of the legs involved,
or one of the particle
involves, has a correction
to its own mass and energy.
This is the so-called
self-energy diagram.
And if you do the
counting correctly,
you find that there's
five of those diagrams.
Here shown, we have a
correction of particle A.
But you could also have a
correction of particle C or B
in the outgoing legs and
obviously also in this particle
here.
The second form of
diagrams is one where you
correct the vertex involved.
So here there's two
diagrams correcting
each of the vertices, and
so this is shown here.
So apparently this changes
then how the vertex actually
looks to the outgoing legs.
So instead of
directly interacting
in this primitive vertex, you
have this interaction here
in those two additional
vertices here.
So this changes
intrinsically how
the interaction, how the
strength of the interaction
looks like.
And then there's
the form of diagrams
which we discussed in the
context of CP violation,
so-called box diagrams where
you just go around in a box.
That's why they're
called box diagrams.
And apparently also here
you change the strength
of the interaction involved.
So those are three
varieties of classes
of higher-order diagrams.
And we will see
much more of those
when we talk about QED, the weak
interaction, or QCD later on.
The strength of the
individual couplings
involved and the
particles involved
changes in how the resulting
features of interaction
change using those diagrams.